[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم على وقع تصاعد
الاحتجاجات الرافضه للتعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل
يتفقان على تاجيل بحثها الى دوره الكنيسه
القادمه ورئيس الاركان يحذر من ان البلاد
تمر بتهديدات خارجيه واحداث داخليه غير
مسبوقه في حين اعرضت واشنطن ودول غربيه عن
قلقها ازاء الوضع وحذرت من التداعيات
في اخبار حرب اوكرانيا المانيا تعلن تسليم
كياف ثمانيه عشره دبابه من طراز ليبرد
والكريم لن يؤكد ان انتقادات الغرب لن
تغير خطط نشر اسلحه نوويه استراتيجيه في
بيلاروسيا في وقت اجرت فيه منسك منورات
لمنظومات الدفاع الجوي المقدمه من روسيا
الجزيره تحصل على مسوده الاتفاق النهائي
بين العسكريين والقوى البدنيه في السودان
المسوده تنص على اصلاح امني يقود الى جيش
مهني ينعن السياسه والاقتصاد وتتضمن اطلاق
عمليه شامله لتحقيق العداله الانتقاليه
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن الجرائد
الصحه الاسكتلنديه حمزه يوسف يفوز بزعامه
الحزب القومي ليتولى رئاسه الحكومه خلفا
لنكولا التي اعلنت استقالتها وبذلك يصبح
اول مسلم يتولى زعامه حزب رئيسي في
المملكه المتحده ومن المقرر ان يصوت
البرلمان غدا الثلاثاء على توليه رئاسه
الحكومه الى اللقاء